but joining us on behalf of shamrock
farms
rock and protein everybody uh is uh
somebody who
uh i greatly appreciate in terms of uh
his
19 years in the league and also
seeing him um talk about it and be about
it and
have a an interesting broadcasting
career in his own right that he's
launching in
nba champion richard jefferson how are
you doing richard i'm doing great how
are you doing i'm doing fine
so you spent some time in the bubble yay
or nay
oh yes lots of times lots of times how
long
it was uh i was there 40 days oh my god
yeah yeah and it's but it's funny though
like there were people that were there a
hundred plus days so
you know there was no room for oh man
i've been here so long people would look
at you and scowl
so i learned to kind of keep uh my
amount of time uh in general population
kind of to myself
no i just i i'm not i'm not fully aware
of what your
drinking or eating habits might be was
the coffee as bad as jimmy butler said
it was
in the bubble look i'm not a big coffee
drinker and
and you know jimmy is you know guys are
connoisseurs some people are kind
connoisseurs of wine
and video games and coffee and jimmy is
a coffee connoisseur a lot of people
know it but i did discover
cubing coffee we had some really really
good guys uh a part of the crew
that were handing out cuban coffee and i
had never had it before and that stuff
is intense well i'll tell you uh i don't
know if you had the same crew as maybe
we did when we were down in south
florida for the super bowl when they
were serving us some cuban coffee
and uh if anybody's ever had five hour
energy it's really five-second energy
when you have one of those
oh my god it hits you it it hits you
really quick and you're like
i'm ready to take over the world and by
the time you finish that sentence you're
like i'm ready for a nap
yes it was quite a roller coaster ride
uh you know when it happened wow so
but in all seriousness how how difficult
do you think it was to play
obviously playing basketball in the nba
is a privilege
um but yeah to do it in those
circumstances
i mean what was that like when you saw
firsthand with what you saw richard
well you know it was so eerie because i
was there i got there right as the
conference final started yep
and i remember the first time i got
there and i go to the first game i
wanted to see an experience and first of
all shout out to the nba
and espn and turn the the setup was
beautiful
right it wasn't big but it was like you
could see it on tv all the boards and
the graphics and all that stuff
they did such a good job considering the
situation
but i remember it was like the announcer
goes ladies and gentlemen the los
angeles lakers and the guys run out
almost like it's a joke they run out and
they're like hey
yeah and it was like if you saw there
was no like crazy intros
guys weren't doing the 12 handshakes
that they do
it was very like let's get to business
and
whoever handled that the best and i'm
not even saying the lakers handled it
the best but
of the good teams i think the lakers
handle is the best it's between the
clippers and the box and even the
celtics
uh those are the teams that if people
had to pick like high level teams that
they thought would do better
i think it's because they just didn't
handle the environment and i think
that's a compliment to the teams like
the denver nuggets like the miami heat
the los angeles lakers the teams that
could kind of tweak their mentality to
be like hey
you know this is what it is who can
handle this the best because ultimately
that's what any championship is about
doesn't matter if it's college high
school professionals any sport
who can handle the environment that
they're in the best is typically the
team that comes out on top
interestingly enough richard jefferson
here on the rich eisen show the lakers
did not handle it well at all when it
was the
if you will regular season portion of
the bubble it looked like they were
sleepwalking through it and then when
the playoffs hit
they uh it was winning time to use the
the phrase that that lebron eventually
used when
it came to the denver nuggets uh another
team however that did not handle it very
well one would say
based on results you'd say the milwaukee
bucks now do you think it was the bubble
or the fact that maybe their lead player
is a
pippen richard what do you think you're
such a jerk
you're
two things let me say this two things
one i think the
if i had one critique about the entire
comeback schedule is that
they took away every motivation for the
top team
the fact that those eight games did not
count towards
possible home court advantage did not
count toward
like regular season awards right so
giannis
had nothing to play for braun and a.d
had nothing to play for
so you took motivation away from those
players in those teams
so they were just kind of sleepwalking
there was like preseason games
and it didn't make sense to me because
the points that you scored
counted towards your regular season
numbers right right so when dan lillard
scored 60 he was the first person
to score 60 three times in a regular
season
since will chamberlain and james harden
so that counted
but none of it counted towards the
awards so i think if it would have
counted towards the awards then giannis
would have been like yo i'm out here
fighting for an mvp
if the lakers go 8-0 and he's got and
the lakers have this record
maybe braun gets more mvp votes so
giannis and braun and all these
players they really tried to tone it
down and then when it came the
postseason they weren't able to turn it
up now
to my pippin comments yes people were
very jumping on it and look you can't
really say things at 160 characters but
i stand by it i think giannis is one of
the great players of this generation
he's so talented
but he is not the player to finish games
for you it's just not it's like
you can't shoot 60 from the free-throw
line in air ball free throws
you can't not shoot a legitimate jumper
or a legitimate three
and think that you're going to be the
individual that's going to finish and
dominate games
like that's just not the reality of the
situation and lebron james struggled
with that
early on in his career not to the same
extent but just like
he had to develop his jump shot he said
that against the spurs
um after playing against them the first
time that that he really needed to
improve his jump shot
um and you've got to shoot free throws
well it's like look shaq is great but
shaq also had kobe
jack had b weighed shaq had pippen and
maybe i shouldn't have said
that he is that he is pippin he's
probably closer to a version of
shaquille o'neal
that can be dominant for 46 minutes
but he needs a closer next to him but
you need a closer that can do it at a
high high level
right not just a guy that's like oh he's
good in the clutch he's like no you need
a
jimmy butler dame lillard type player
around him to finish it off no and
and i understand what you said when you
said it richard and i'll be honest with
you it's not just because you share the
same first name i
i agree with you um you know and and
that and that
pippin is still and the way you if it's
just say he's a pippen
not a jordan um you know in a hundred
and
you know less than 280 characters it
does leave out the fact that pippin is a
top 50 nba player of all time
and is stellar in his own right but
when it comes down to it you know when
it comes down to it
jordan was the guy who has the ball in
his hands when it's time to win it and
if giannis is not that guy then it's a
problem so
you are the perfect person to ask this
question
because we on this show have had a
little bit of an
argument over the last couple of weeks
certainly seeing
what no no no seeing what the miami heat
have done
and how they wound up the season would
you
would you break up the heat to go get
giannis
would you do that one thousand percent i
break up the lake
i break up the lakers to go see
so how do you square how do you square
both of those
those statements though well well this
is what i'm saying though
like when i say like like giannis like
it's not a disrespect when i was saying
these terms and i was saying this stuff
as
rich you know what i'm saying is goddess
is still a top
two top three player in the league and
that's 25 or 26 years old you want that
guy on your team
but it's just like every player has a
formula lebron james
needs shooters around him he needs
shooters around them and guys that can
knock down shots because he creates
often
magic johnson and jason kidd and steve
nash these guys needed athletes around
them
uh shaquille o'neal needed a late game
finisher
around him and he had that in all the
players like like we talked about
earlier whether it was
kobe or d wade he needed that that was
the formula for him
giannis has a formula and the milwaukee
bucks have not figured out that formula
yet
and so um you know he's a great player
and i think if you had to break up
you know the milwaukee bucks and and or
if you had the break of
the the miami heat and you had to send
tyler hero you had to send duncan
robinson
there's probably not a player on that
roster that i wouldn't trade
for giannis that's including jimmy
butler and bam adebayo because you know
where it goes
in my opinion it goes to the same
conversation i think the young players
of the miami heat are better
but it goes to the same conversation
that the lakers had about giving away
all of their young talent to go get
anthony davis
i don't give a damn what lonzo ball
brandon ingram josh
i don't care what any of those dudes are
doing you give me anthony davis and i'm
gonna figure it out
yeah but lonzo and and ingram and
everybody else who's now a pelican never
made the finals i mean hiro is 20.
autobio is is is a a
stud i mean so no rich
bridge the one thing that i'll say is
this yes from being in that bubble into
being there
yes i am not surprised that a lot of
young players had great
breakout seasons in a con like a
confined area
like he never had like tyler hero never
had to go to boston i'm not saying type
of hero couldn't
like silence a boston crowd like he
showed us that he's got that kind of
mentality but there is something
different about having to travel having
to go
to opposing crowds and doing it for the
first time in your life
if you've never experienced that in the
booze and the hatred and all that stuff
that's just a different experience so
i will still say the miami heat are
proven but not completely
all right so how do you think it how do
you think it does shake out because the
minute
the minute giannis if he does say no
super max the bucks have got to ship him
somewhere
right so how do you i i i think and what
i'm hearing this is not a quote from me
i think he's going to do
similar things to like what a lot of
great players to do even what you look
at what to happen with the clippers
where they'll do
like two plus one or one plus one maybe
he doesn't sign the five-year deal
maybe he says like hey i want one plus
one you know and you could keep
re-upping because what that does
is that forces teams into the tax
milwaukee bucks have to go into the tax
of in the last like 12 years there's
been two teams
that have won the championship that
weren't in the three teams i think
one of the teams was the warrior but
steph curry was on a
on a team friendly contract because he
signed it early
and then the next time it was the
warriors with kevin durant and the only
reason why they weren't
over the cap is because the salary cap
had ballooned so big
because of the nike deal on the tv deal
but traditionally
the talent on that level was an over the
capped team so for the milwaukee bucks
if you want to keep giannis if you want
to win a championship there's a lot of
different formulas and one of the
formulas is that you're going to have to
spend money and go in the tax
and so when you do a one in one contract
or two in one contract a shorter form
then the team now knows that they have
to keep spending money
in order to keep you because i don't
care what that tax bill is
you know what's going to really affect
them if giannis leads because ticket
sales jersey sales tv
all that stuff is going to be gone from
the bucks if he's not there
richard jefferson espn nba analyst here
on the rich eisen show and also on
behalf of shamrock farms rockin pro team
why'd you partner with these people
richard matt rich man i grew up in
phoenix arizona and that's where
shamrock farms is and and that's where
they have all their signs and when they
called me
and i've always been you know even now
going to the bubble and i you know try
and stay in shape and try and work out
and people are like
oh you look like you can still play and
it's like no it's really
because i just enjoy working out i enjoy
training i always have this even as a
kid i would just play outside all damn
day and
uh you know trying to stay in shape
especially as i get older
you know there's you know so many
protein drinks and protein shakes and
when i found this and already had a
relationship with shamrock farms it was
it was kind of a no-brainer being the
hometown kid and
uh being able to partner with with
something that one tastes great
two i already had a connection with
growing up and so
you know these are one of those things
that like you know i used to drive by
their big sign go into practice every
day and so to be able to work with a
product that you know i'm familiar with
i grew up with that taste great
that you know actually has a function
you know every time you work out you
know they every even
in any gym any league they tell you make
sure you get your protein make sure you
get your protein so
it's quick it's easy it tastes great man
and it's been
really really one of those cool things i
was like yo i get to endorse something
after i retire that's correct that's
cool that's kind of cool that's great uh
shamrock farms rock and protein
uh richard one last one for you before
you go i'm enjoying this conversation i
hope you are too
um rich whenever you want me on man you
know you're my guy
i appreciate you saying that because
you're again you're you're
you've been there you've done that and
you shy away from nothing
so then can you interpret kyrie irving's
comments on that
etcetera's podcast where he said that
for the first time in his career with
durant he's got
uh let me get this quote correctly um
i've got it right here it just went away
if you don't have it you don't have to
get it
his ability to deliver in this it's
called into question his ability to
deliver in the clutch
it seemed like the first time in his
career he said the best option that he
said uh where i can be
like that uh mfr can make that shot too
but interpret them you know it's weird
and kyrie i don't want to say took a
step back kyrie said like look i'm not
taking shots i'm not doing any of that
stuff but rich how long have you been
covering sports
uh this is gonna be my 25th year sir
your 25th year yes so you've watched mj
you've watched kobe you've bought all
these guys can you interpret that
conversation
uh yeah um i
i
that he's either forgotten about lebron
james or he wants to make a point at
lebron's expense to
to talk about how much he loves being a
teammate at durant those are the two
things
that i would interpret because this is
the thing i respect
individuals that have covered sports and
watch sports and you know
more like i was a kid watching the bulls
that you were like covering them
you know as much as i do like there's
only a couple of ways that you can
interpret it just because like i played
with them and
you know and i get it it's like we all
read it and watch it and we're just like
there's only a couple of ways to take
this and none of them are good
none of them are good but i don't think
kyrie sometimes like
i all of us we say things and we and we
mention things in a moment and we don't
like fully look at it in a way like he
was trying to give his teammate a
compliment
but it was taken as a diss to somebody
else i don't think anybody in the world
thinks that you know lebron james can't
make that shot it's been proven
too many times over the last two decades
so i just think that like i think in an
effort to complement somebody
it was taken you know i don't want to
say out of context i'm just going to say
it it put focus on somebody else and i
don't think that was his intention
richard thanks for the call
let's chat again real soon i really
appreciate you offering to come on
anytime we're going to take you up on
that for
that's for sure all right you take care
of my guy tj too man
you take care of my guy tj i hope you're
doing well man tj brother
t.j uh now again uh i i i don't want to
take it out of context
but by him saying that is he implying
i'm not taking care of you
i think he's just 100 percent
have you given richard jefferson the
impression i have not he's i think he
just wants to make sure that
everything's copacetic
okay yeah yeah wait wait tj are you
still a bears fan
no that was kutcher i'm the cowboys oh
no oh the cowboy fans you know what
i just remember sitting there and
watching you just moan about your
fantasy football league
and it was just you know but again
you're i knew it was a long-standing
disgusting theme and it was had to
either be the bears or the cowboys so
okay i wasn't too far off i knew it was
somebody you're doing all right after
the back injury
i i'm telling you man i was numb i was
numb till about wednesday
it just was it was terrible to see sorry
rich i'm ranting rich i'm sorry that i
this is now the richard jefferson show
no it's
interviewing tj jefferson it's quite
jefferson's we're moving
up it's it's it's quite all right like
lebron i'm able to pass it off to the
open man and hope he hits the shot
richard
all right well thank you guys so much
for having me seriously anytime you guys
want you got it
jefferson again on behalf of shamrock
farms rock and protein
you like that video of course you did
check out more right here